>> Tiled allows an artist to do multiple layers per map tile, meaning that we
can potentially do 10 draws per on screen tile. Sadly, our bounding view
rectangle won't help us fix this in performance terms, so we have to employ a
new technique. Now, as you've played Grids, you'll notice that their environment
is mostly static. Which means that we could, hypothetically, add export time
from the map editor. Actually composite our entire map into a single image. At
run time, this means instead of doing 200 to 2000 draw calls, we could only do
one. So this is not necessarily ideal, having a single large image representing
the background of our map. Because of the fact that that's actually a pretty big
image and it would take time to download that off the internet. Now, we can't
deny the fact that this would help on the client's side for rendering. So, it'd
be nice to find a way to mix both these techniques together so that we can
improve rendering and reduce download time. Thankfully, Canvas provides a
technique called Off Screen Canvas Rendering that allows a single canvas to be
used an, an image element for future draws. So let's say we create an off-screen
canvas. And in this canvas, we draw lots of little happy figures. Or happy
trees. Later, when we'd like to actually draw this to our main canvas. We simply
draw each of the elements using the draw image API. Passing into it the canvas
that we composited before. So, if it took 300 draw calls to composite this
canvas, when we draw to our real image, it will only actually take one for each
time we render it. So, instead of doing 1200 draw calls, we only have to do 4.
Which I think we can all agree is a good thing. Now, in order to support off
screen canvas, we need to keep track of a separate canvas for each tile that
we're creating in our map. We've separated this functionality out into a canvas
tile class. Now, the canvas tile class itself has some boundaries that we should
talk. First, is its x and y value in world space? And its width and its height.
Next, we actually have a handle to the canvas object itself. Or more
specifically, a handle to the canvas DOM object. As well as the handle to the
context for the canvas. The create element for this process should be given a
width and a height. Besides setting up some initial values, the create function
should actually go through and create a brand new canvas element in the DOM and
set its width and height accordingly to the past in values. From there, we cache
that handle, and actually grab a handle to the 2D graphics context for the
canvas we just created.